(gentle guitar music)
[Kim] Hey, Rob, this is Kim Katie
from Louisville, Kentucky.
So today you wake up and you
decide to write a screenplay
set in Dayton, Ohio.
Yes, that's right.
What story would you tell
and who would you cast?
Name three people you
really want to work with
outside of yourself, and
that's my question for today.
I've read all your books,
love your podcast, and
hope you have a great day.
Thanks.
Thank you, Kim, for calling in
and also thank you for reading the books.
Always like to hear that.
Well, there's two things at play here.
There's what I would
write about Dayton, Ohio,
and who I would cast,
and then who my three favorite people are.
So I gotta figure out do
my three favorite people,
oh, actually!
I was worried about having my
three favorite people be able
to be in my Dayton, Ohio, story.
So Joaquin Phoenix is, I
think, my favorite actor
at the moment, and I think
he's going to play Papine.
Papine was the neighborhood
hood in Dayton, Ohio,
who may or may not have been
like, you know, convict.
Yeah, he was like the rough,
he might've had a switchblade
and he would, you know, steal
things and he was the guy
we all kind of looked up to as a bad-ass.
So maybe Joaquin Phoenix
in the Papine ding-dong-ditch
stealing, you know, you know,
petty things out of the grocery store.
And then eight-year-old Rob Lowe going,
"Wow, I want to be like Papine."
Unfortunately Papine
met his his untimely end
when he was being chased by the police
and jumped over a barbed wire fence
and the barbed wire
caught him in the nut sack
and he was rushed to the hospital
and we never saw Papine again.
That might prevent Joaquin
Phoenix from doing the role,
but that is the truth and
truth is, as you know,
stranger than fiction.